- [Voiceover] Hello Grammarians.
Hello Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi David.
- [Voiceover] I say hello to you
and I say hello to the grammarians.
- [Voiceover] That was an
interesting thing to say.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it's cause
there's a compound sentence.
- [Voiceover] I see.
- [Voiceover] So there's this
distinction made in grammar,
between simple and compound sentences.
And today Paige, you and I are going
to cover those differences.
- [Voiceover] Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] So, a simple
sentence is really just
what it says on the 10.
A simple sentence consists of one subject
and one predicate, and that's it.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So in the sentence,
I bought my friends some candy,
alright we got our one subject, I.
And then we have our one predicate,
bought my friends some candy.
- [Voiceover] Mhmm.
- [Voiceover] Now all of this together is
what we call an independent clause.
I don't wanna hit that too hard right now.
But you know, when you have this set of
subject and a predicate together,
and it can be a sentence, that's called
an independent clause.
I'm not even gonna write that down.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] But a compound
sentence is basically
two or more simple
sentences joined together.
So that would be two
subjects plus two predicates.
Or more, two, three, a bajillion.
- [Voiceover] Sure.
- [Voiceover] That would be
a very long sentence to read,
but you could do it, it would be
a very very compound sentence.
So I visited the beach and
I got a really bad sunburn.
When we're looking at this,
this is really two sentences
together, joined by
the comma and this and.
Alright, so we have our subject,
I visited the beach, I
got a really bad sunburn.
And we have our two predicates,
I visited the beach, got
a really bad sunburn.
- [Voiceover] So the
subject in both these cases
is I right, but it's sort of separate.
It's like, I'm doing
two different actions.
- [Voiceover] Correct.
- [Voiceover] What's
important is even if it's
the same subject, if it's I both times.
Well I don't know how to say this,
but just, if it were, I visited the beach
and got a really bad sunburn.
- [Voiceover] Then it
would be a simple sentence.
- [Voiceover] Then it's simple.
- [Voiceover] Okay so
Paige, I'm looking at this
and I see I twice.
What if I wanted to condense
this sentence further?
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] What does that give us?
Is this a simple sentence
or a compound sentence?
Because this looks like
what you would call
a compound predicate.
- [Voiceover] Right, since
there's only one subject
in this sentence, there's only
I and it's only said once.
Right, you don't have, I visited the beach
and I got a really bad sunburn.
That whole thing, visited the beach
and got a really bad sunburn,
is you're right, it is
a compound predicate.
- [Voiceover] But what
you're saying is I couldn't
divide this up into two sentences,
unless I put in another subject.
Right, you can say, I visited the beach,
and that could be a sentence on its own.
But you can't say, and
got a really bad sunburn,
as it's own sentence.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so both
of these things are simple.
So even though this is
a compound predicate,
it's technically one predicate.
- [Voiceover] Right, it's --
- [Voiceover] And even if I'd written,
Paige and I visited the beach
and I got a really bad sunburn,
that would still be a compound subject,
but it wouldn't be two
sentences squished together,
it would be one kind of long sentence.
- [Voiceover] Right.
You can have a compound subject
or a compound predicate,
but that doesn't make
it a compound sentence.
What makes it a compound sentence,
is you have two parts that
can stand on their own
as individual sentences, and they're
sort of being put together.
- [Voiceover] So let me
change what I wrote here,
to just say, instead of two
subjects and two predicates.
Cause I think that's confusing in light of
this information, let's just
say it is two simple sentences.
- [Voiceover] Right, or
two independent clauses.
You know, that terminology.
- [Voiceover] Or two, yeah.
And if you don't, never
fear, we'll cover it,
and you can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.